[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler claude
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir que
blanchemaison à vos côtés et le saunier
grand reporter qui connaît évidemment
très bien l'afghanistan puisque régis
vous ayez passé trois semaines pour un
reportage en juillet bonsoir donc à tous
les deux merci d'être avec nous cette
vallée un dernier foyer d'opposition aux
talibans qui serait tombée selon ces
derniers alors pas forcément selon le
front national de résistance déjà qui
doit-on croire résister sony je pense
qu'à l'heure actuelle il faut croire les
têtes du bon même si il ya des villes va
restait des poches de régicide de
résistance dans le panshir qui est une
vallée très très escarpé c'est un cetain
comment un couloir de montagne entre
deux montagnes qui est très difficile
d'atteinte pour rappel quand l'union
soviétique avait envahi l'afghanistan il
ya eu quatre assauts sur le panchir et
jamais aucun n'a abouti et le commandant
massoud est sous le joug soviétique et
sous les taliban a continué à résister
donc il est fort à parier que son fils
aussi à peut-être les moyens de résister
dans des endroits isolés ce sont des
montagnards ce sont des gens qui sont
habitués à la haute montagne de la
vallée du panjshir culmine à 5600 mètres
et donc ils sont capables de 2,2 voilà
d'avoir une des points de résistance
néanmoins là les talibans quand même
pénétré dans la vallée ils ont quand
même repris un certain nombre de
districts on peut considérer que ils ont
conquis en gros ils ont atteint leur
objectif
faut le rappeler avec beaucoup d aide de
la part de l'armée pakistanaise dans ce
jeu vous suis bien c'est très symbolique
ce qui vient de se classer bien sûr et
c'est la première fois que bien sûr une
belle prise puisque c'est la première
fois que les taliban parviennent à
prendre cette vallée val et symbole de
leur résistance par parme et par dessus
tout ahmad shah massoud
qui a été donc tu es le rappel le 9
septembre 2001 donc il ya 20 ans
quasiment voilà que blanchemaison l'iran
a condamné fermement cet assaut contre
le pen scheer une une critique
d'ailleurs la première de téhéran depuis
la prise de pouvoir des talibans
pourquoi cette première critique à ce
moment là hier le gouvernement iranien
s'était exprimé en disant qu'il fallait
résoudre le problème par le dialogue
en présence d'ailleurs des chefs
traditionnels des différentes tribus et
aurait été je crois qu'il ya trois
motifs
l'attitude de l'iran qui a une frontière
très longue avec l'afghanistan le
premier c'est que l'iran n'a pas envie
d'avoir un voisin dans lequel il y a des
troubles qui pourraient se répandre
ailleurs le second c'est que
l'iran n'a pas envie d'avoir un voisin
fait or l'afghanistan est un pays en
fait puisque 75% des recettes
budgétaires c'était là d'international
et que l'aide internationale
elle est suspendue elle n'arrive plus
par conséquent il ya là un problème très
très important et puis troisièmement en
effet comme ça vient d'être dit l'iran
est très inquiet du rôle que joue le
pakistan le pakistan protecteur
historique des talibans et qui se
manifeste un peu partout d'abord imran
khan s'est réjoui un petit peu
bruyamment le 15 août de la victoire des
talibans et puis aujourd'hui le chef des
services secrets
militaires et interservices du pakistan
est à kaboul alors bien sûr il est là
pour des contacts techniques en réalité
on sait qu'il est là pour organiser un
commandement unifié de la nouvelle armée
afghane qui réunira à la fois les
talibans ce qu'ils ont récupéré
l'ancienne armée afghane mais aussi les
les chefs de guerre traditionnels les
seigneurs de la guerre comme on disait
tu auparavant et qu'il est là aussi sans
doute pour mettre un terme aux querelles
inter talibane et pour aider à la
formation d'un gouvernement d'un
gouvernement taliban on va en reparler
évidemment de ce gouvernement tout
d'abord je voudrais vous faire écouter
jeu souvent cet appel du fils du
commandant massoud à la résistance et
côté
où que vous soyez dedans et en dehors de
l'afghanistan je vous appelle à lancer
un soulèvement national pour la dignité
la liberté et la prospérité de notre
pays on a commencé à en parler tout à
l'heure régis le sommier mais à quel
point cet appel peut-il être entendu est
ce que cette résistance est ce qu elle a
un petit peu de chance justement de
résister de et de gêner l'expansion
énorme et des talibans je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est quand même eu
largement trop tôt pour le dire ce qu'on
a pu le montrer ce qu'on a pu remarquer
de toute façon donc en afghanistan c'est
que les talibans ne doivent pas oublier
que l'afghanistan qu'il récupère
aujourd'hui n'est pas tout à fait le
même que celui qu'ils avaient laissé
pourtant dans leur chute il y a vingt
ans largement les villes se sont
ouvertes sur le monde
kaboul a été occidentalisée s'ils ont pu
le dire a vécu à l'unisson avec le reste
de la planète et l'idée d'une chape de
plomb
traditionalistes et d'un gouvernement
obscurs comme il est comme il s'était
exercé entre 96 et 2001 est quelque
chose que beaucoup de gens dans les
villes notamment pour eux c'est assez
insupportable de revenir à ça et les
talibans le savent ils sont allés à
l'offensive dans la communication cette
fois ci il n'y a pas eu les exactions il
ya eu des exactions mais il n'y a pas eu
les exactions publiquement admise qui
avait été le guen qui avait salué leur
victoire en 96 avec des pendaisons des
lapidations des assassinats dans les
stades tout ça n'a pas eu lieu cette
fois-ci les talibans savent très bien
que ils jouent gros ils jouent leur
survie il joue aussi un moment critique
vous avez évoqué les seigneurs de la
guerre tout à fait ils sont seuls ceux
là veulent conserver leurs prérogatives
il ya des tensions entre les talibans
entre notamment la branche militaire et
une branche entre guillemets plus
modérée incarné par le mollah baradar
encore que le mollah baradar est un
ancien compagnon de route du mollah omar
de la précédente équipe et que le chef
des talibans aujourd'hui
akoun zada le mollah akoun zada était
responsable de l'administration de la
justice de l'ancienne équipe talibane
donc on peut pas dire que ce soit
fondamentalement des modérés si vous
voulez mais ils sont prêts à jouer une
carte internationale ils ont envie que
de renouer des liens avec leurs voisins
ils sont partis ce parfum partiellement
parvenu on parlait de l'iran tout à
l'heure l'iran s'est rapproché des
talibans ce qui n'était pas le cas avant
2001 elle avait même l'iran avait même
fait partie de la coalition contre les
talibans en novembre 2001 qui avaient
peu conduit à la chute du régime donc
aujourd'hui la plupart des pays autour
veulent avoir des relations avec les
talibans et les talibans un défi majeur
c'est bien d'être dans les campagnes
avec des kalachnikovs de faire peur à
tout le monde et ensuite d'arriver le
conquérir le pays ensuite maintenant le
défi il est économique le défilé
sociétal également et on a vu où parler
de l'opposition effectivement le ahmad
masood incarne une forme de cette
opposition moi je la vois plus tôt
aujourd'hui dans les femmes qui
manifestent dans les villes qu'ils
n'hésitent pas à venir braver les
combattants taliban qui ne les
respectent il ya des tensions mais ya
pas eu de 2,2 d'incidents et des femmes
ont pu montrer donner leur voix et
montrer qu'elles sont là et ça c'est des
femmes qui ont bénéficié de l'éducation
aujourd'hui les talibans tandis que les
universités étaient à nouveau admise
pour les femmes à condition de porter un
uniquement le niqab et la bahia d'accord
mais au moins les femmes peuvent aller à
l'université ce qui n'était pas le cas
avant 2001 vous qu'il ya quand même des
choses qui avancent et cette résistance
elle est peut-être un carnet justement
par ces gens là claude gans maison
justement j'allais y venir à cette
manifestation des femmes à à kaboul qui
n'a pas été effectivement trop contrarié
est-ce qu'on est peut-être dans la
communication de la part des talibans
qui cherchent à voilà à être crédible un
interlocuteur crédible ou est ce que on
me dit régis le sommier ça pourrait être
peut-être là la future résistance de
l'afghanistan même si la grande question
il ya un débat dans quelle mesure les
talibans ont ils changé et avec sont ils
les mêmes où ont-ils changé par rapport
à la dernière fois qu'ils étaient au
pouvoir entre 96 et 2001 alors ils ont
changé dans une certaine mesure de toute
façon le monde a changé autour d'eux et
ils s'en rendent bien compte et ils ont
appris beaucoup de choses il parle
anglais pour beaucoup l'ont en tout cas
leurs responsables ce qui était au qatar
ont pu négocier pendant des mois et des
mois avec les américains le fameux
mollah baradar qui se présente comme la
face
acceptable du mouvement qui pourrait
peut-être devenir premier ministre dans
un gouvernement fait pour séduire
l'extérieur mais en effet il ya des
luttes intestines parce que
fondamentalement leur socle fondamental
c'est le socle religieux est le même
pour tous sur le plan religieux je crois
pas qu'il y ait des modérés et les
extrémistes ils sont tous en effet pour
une application stricte de leur
interprétation du coran de leur
interprétation de la vie du prophète de
l'arête interprétation de la
jurisprudence et serra et c'est une
interprétation qui est extrêmement
respectée c'est à dire que les femmes
n'ont pas vraiment de place alors en
effet moyennant un certain nombre de
conditions dont certaines sont
totalement ridicules il faut que jeune
fille à l'université sorte avant les
garçons on les stocke dans une pièce ou
un amphithéâtre qui n'existent pas
qu'elles attendent que les garçons
soient sortis pour ensuite pouvoir
sortir elle même mais en réalité
l'épreuve de vérité va être le
gouvernement et le gouvernement y
aura-t-il des femmes je pense que non y
aura-t-il des gens qui ne soient pas des
talibans par exemple abdallah abdallah
qui en rêvent
probablement il aura un strapontin ainsi
la branche
baradar obtient ce qu'elle veut obtenir
hamid karzaï s'est plus douteux mais il
aura peut-être un poste honorifique là
aussi s'il s'agit de séduire l'occident
est de faire lever les sanctions et et
d'obtenir l'aide internationale ce qui
est ce qui est maintenant en effet vital
pour le pour le pays avant de vous
donner la parole en légiste soumillon va
coûter
le secrétaire d'état américain qui au
qatar on en reparlera si on a le temps
effectivement qu'il soit aussi ce
gouvernement inclusif
nous espérons que tout gouvernement mis
en place aura une vraie inclusivité
qu'il y aura dedans des noms talibans
qui soit représentatif des différentes
communautés et les différents intérêts
en afghanistan
mais résiste au sommier ce souhait de
voir des femmes au gouvernement c'est un
souhait à l'apurement occidental où ça
qu'on va perdu d'avancé
c'est un combat à mon avis perdu
d'avancé ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
dans parlement afghan précédemment il y
avait beaucoup de femmes il y en avait
il y en avait un certain nombre donné de
la voix d'ailleurs certaines
parlementaires étaient très incisif
notamment sur le droit des femmes et
combattait à la fois les talibans et
aussi certains certaines comment
certains seigneurs de guerre à
l'intérieur du gouvernement ou des gens
qui étaient proches du gouvernement donc
le combat des femmes avaient commencé
déjà avant maintenant ce que je vois
dans l'est dans le discours de blink n 7
ce souhait d'inclusivité il s'est tout
simplement le plan que les américains
avaient souhaité avec les talibans à
partir de février de 2020 quand ils ont
fait cet accord de paix avec les
talibans des talibans d'une certaine
façon respecter vis-à-vis des américains
n'ont pas tenu leurs promesses vis à vis
du gouvernement afghan mais vis-à-vis
des américains partir de février 2020 ya
plus un soldat américain qui est blessé
ou tué par un tir talibans donc là d'une
certaine façon oui ils sont tenus mais
ce que voient les américains au delà
c'est l'intérêt d'avoir un gouvernement
inclusif d'essayer de faire pression
là-dessus les talibans on n'a vu l'autre
cote de l'autre côté habitent ou là
l'autre jour d'hier nous souhaitons
avoir de bonnes relations avec les états
unis donc on est finalement dans le
prolongement de tous ces accords et que
voilà même si le départ des américains a
été extrêmement chaotique pour les
américains c'était quelque chose qui
devait avoir lieu blinken et ben on dit
que ce soit aujourd'hui vous dans cinq
ans ça n'aurait rien changé à la
configuration du pays donc autant partir
la question aujourd'hui c'est que d'un
point de vue géopolitique l'afghanistan
n'intéresse plus les américains ils
veulent juste partir en laissant le
moins d'instabilité possible dans la
région c'est leur souhait c'est
également leur souhait pour le monde
arable puisqu'il ya quand même
l'amérique est tué sur une position de
retrait de ces guerres et deux de ses
interventions qui ont duré des décennies
donc donc quelque part les américains
essayer de jouer la pression sur ce
nouveau gouvernement taliban en espérant
potentiellement avoir quelques personnes
qui puissent d'une certaine façon
apporter un gage de modération est un
gage de stabilité pour l'ensemble de la
région voilà qu'à le suspense reste
entier pour l'instant on ne connaît pas
le visage de ce nouveau gouvernement
parlait d' anthony blinken 1 le
secrétaire d'état américain qui est
attendu au qatar là d'un instant à
l'autre on en parlait avec thomas bonnet
le canard qatar décidément qui est
devenu incontournable dans ce dossier
afghan au qatar le secrétaire d'état à
la défense américain et arrivent ce soir
je crois
le ministre des affaires étrangères
britannique qui était il ya peu de temps
la france a envoyé la r11 représentant
un ambassadeur pour sonder un peu les
talibans et voir dans quelle mesure il
va les respecter ce qui pour nous est
important notamment continuer à
autoriser à les départs et ça ça va être
une autre opération vérité il n'est pas
sûr que leur filtrage autour de
l'aéroport soit particulièrement
bienveillants puisqu'on sait que depuis
qu'ils sont dans les villes ils ont
interrogé les gens ils ont interrogé les
voies les voisins ils ont filé liste de
collaborateurs alors il ya deux sortes
de collaborateurs tous sont
théoriquement gracié mais ceux qui
étaient dans des postes vraiment
critique très importants qui ont eu
affaire avec les talibans ont maille à
partir avec l'aliment probablement
seront inquiétés
et les familles de ceux qui sont partis
seront aussi probablement inquiété donc
il ya lieu en effet de craindre pour
cela et puis on n'a pas encore dit mais
dans le fond puisqu'il va y avoir un
sujet économique qui va prendre en
charge la reconstruction de
l'afghanistan
et s'il n'y a pas un gouvernement
inclusif comme on dit eh bien il ya un
pays qui est candidat il ya un pays qui
est candidat c'est la chine et la chine
en effet va leur dire 'attendez route de
la soie investissement les autoroutes
que les américains n'ont pas fait les
chemins de fer que les américains n'ont
pas construit nous nous pouvons vous les
faire et d'ailleurs on va vous en été un
petit peu comme ça ça nous donnera un
pied de plus sur le terrain puisqu'il ya
évidemment beaucoup de matières
premières c'est un pays très riche en
matières premières qui ont été
totalement délaissé dans le passé régis
le sommier ce spectre chinois il devient
de plus en plus imminent d'une certaine
façon il est il et il n'est pas le
récent les chinois le ministre affaires
étrangères chinois s'était affichée avec
une délégation talibane comme les russes
également y avait eu une visite de
délégations à beausoleil en mars dernier
avec les chinois le ministre des
affaires étrangères s'est affiché bien
avant au mois de juillet bien avant le
comment le la chute de kaboul donc cette
d'ailleurs les pakistanais ont joué
aussi pas mal pour rapprocher les
chinois avec les talibans et les chinois
ont d'une certaine façon appuyée les
talibans donc ça ça fait partie des pays
qui vise d'abord à une stabilité 1 et
chinois on sait qu'à la question oui
moore qui est à quelques critiques pour
eux il ne s'agirait pas d'avoir un
gouvernement talibans qui alimentent en
en gommant en sous sol une révolte dans
cette partie musulmane de l'est de la
chine de l'ouest de la chine pardon et
ça c'est un obsession des chinois
ensuite pour pour la question de 2,2 de
la russie c'est clair que aussi
l'instabilité dans les anciennes
républiques soviétiques musulmane vous
existant le tadjikistan c'est quand même
très proche et il ya aussi pose
potentiellement des éléments
perturbateurs dont il ya d'ailleurs des
manoeuvres militaires eurent lieu entre
ces pays et la russie pour justement
dire aux talibans attention pas de pas
d'agitation pas de voie là et je pense
que c'est pas du tout dans l'intérêt des
talibans de faire ça mais justement avec
ses deux partenaires en particulier et
avec l'iran qui comme je l'expliqué
c'est s'est considérablement rapproché
des talibans l'afghanistan dont
notamment par le biais du successeur de
souleymane sy qui était le le gardien le
chef des gardiens de la révolution
aujourd'hui et qui étaient ceux qui
étaient spécialisés dans l'afghanistan à
l'époque où sur les manies et l e à la
tête des gardiens de la révolution là il
ya eu véritablement une inflexion et un
rapprochement ya tous ces pays qui sont
là il ya aussi la turquie faut pas
l'oublier qui donc a pas proposé ses
services est en train de négocier pour
la gestion de l'aéroport de kaboul la
question n'est pas tant que la turquie
ait des intérêts énormes mais elle peut
à nouveau se projeter à l'international
et apparaître comme ce qui ne cesse de
vouloir apparaître c'est à dire comme
une puissance véritablement
internationale avec un comment une
sphère d'influencé
et la voilà chacun essaie de combler ce
vide immense laissés par les etats-unis
en afghanistan en attendant le construit
des murs pour éviter les réfugiés
merci en tout cas tous les deux avis le
saunier claude blanche maison